สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 15
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ 201
ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 14 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 16 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมีนาคม
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะ
ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
5 โมง
5 โมง 5 โมงกี่นาที
6 นาทีค่ะ
[เพลง]
เวลาร้อนใช่ไหมอันนี้ครูหญิงใช่ไหมคะนัก
เรียน
เวลาร้อนเนี่ยเราก็จะมีเหงื่อ
น้ำตานะจมูกปากนี้คิ้วนี้แว่นตานะคะก็จะ
มีเหงื่อใช่ไหมคะเหงื่อแล้วก็เวลาชิม
เหงื่อเนี่ยนะคะครูฟ้าอะไรคะ
ตายดีกว่าค่ะ
ผู้หญิงร้อนเนี่ย
ครูฟ้าน่ะอยู่ใกล้กับทะเลไงใช่ไหมทะเล
เราอยู่ใกล้ทะเล
ใช่ทะเลเนี่ยมันร้อนที่ทะเลเนี่ยร้อนครู
ฟ้าก็ไปเล่นน้ำทะเลสิคะ
[เพลง]
เค็มค่ะ
ครูฟ้าเคยชินแล้วหรอคะ
ว่าเคยชิมน้ำทะเล
เค็มเหมือนอะไรคะครูฟ้า
เค็มเหมือนเกลือค่ะ
ใช่ไหมคะเกลือเนี่ยเค็มแต่นักเรียน
นักเรียนอาจจะคนยุโรปคนอเมริกาแล้วกันนะ
คะคนแคนาดานะเวลานักเรียนทำอาหารนักเรียน
ก็จะใส่เกลือให้มันเค็มใช่ไหมคะหรือว่า
นักเรียนมี French  fried
นี่นะคะ
French  file  French  Fries
ผู้หญิงไม่ค่อยเป็นระเบียบเลยอ่ะ
ด้วย
เพราะผู้หญิงมองไม่เห็นวันนี้อ่ะ
จริงหรอ
ใช่ในหน้าจอคุณหญิงเอาปากกาเขียนมันจะไม่
โดนใช่ค่ะ
เฟรนช์ฟรายส์เวลานักเรียนกิน French
Fries ก็จะโรยเกลือ
ให้มันเค็มๆใช่ไหมคะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
แล้วก็จะมีเกลือ
เกลือโรยเฟรนฟรายส์ก็จะเค็มๆใช่ไหมคะ
อย่างครูฟ้าครูหญิงครูฟ้าอยู่ทะเลเนี่ย
บางครั้งเนี่ยคนที่มีบ้านติดทะเล
เลยต้องสีฟ้าใช่ไหมทะเลเนี่ยทะเลทะเลทะเล
ทะเลเนี่ยบางครั้งเนี่ยเราก็จะซื้อเกลือ
ง่ายๆมีเกลือขายเยอะๆไม่แพงเพราะว่าเรามี
ทะเลไงทะเล
ก็เลย
เราก็เลยชอบกินเกลือ
เราไม่ชอบกินเกลือค่ะแต่เราซื้อเกลือทะเล
เนี่ยไม่แพงไง
[เพลง]
มีร่มเนี่ยก็จะขายเกลือขายเกลือขายเกลือ
มากๆไหมครูฟ้าเคยเอ่อครูฟ้าหลับ
บนรถนะคะก็เลยไม่เห็น
แต่ว่าเรื่องนี้นะคะครูหญิงมันก็เหมือน
เรื่องที่คุณฟ้าจะเล่าเลยค่ะ
เรื่องขับรถหรอคะ
เรื่องเกลือ
นักเรียนบอกว่าเกลือสีขาว
โอเคอันนี้นะคะเกลือนักเรียน
นี่คือเกลือ
ไม่มองไม่เห็น
แล้วเราจะทำยังไงให้มันแบบเป็นสีอื่นได้
เกลือ
โอเค
ไฟฟ้าก็ว่าเกลือได้ทำไมคะวันนี้ครูฟ้ามี
เรื่องมาเล่าเกี่ยวกับเกลือเหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะผู้หญิงเรื่องเล่าของพวกนี้นะคะ
เกี่ยวกับเกลือ
มันเล็กๆ
และมันชื่อเรื่องว่า
ลบนะคะ
เรื่องอะไรคะ
เรื่องชื่อเรื่องว่าคนนี่นา
คนใช่ไหม
ใส่หมวกด้วย
วันนี้เนี่ยเป็นพ่อค้าเกลือค่ะ
อ๋อเป็นพ่อค้าเกลือก็แปลว่าคนนี้เนี่ยขาย
เกลือถ้าครูหญิงกับครูฟ้าอยากจะซื้อที่
บ้านที่บ้านเนี่ยไม่มีเกลือแล้วก็ต้องไป
ซื้อกับผู้ชายคนนี้ใช่ไหมเพราะเขาเป็นพ่อ
ค้าขายเกลือเรื่องพ่อค้าขายเกลือเหรอคะ
ครูฟ้า
มีเกลือมีเกลือมีเกลือ
พ่อค้าขายเกลือค่ะเรื่องนี้นะคะซึ่งมัน
ชื่อเรื่องว่าพ่อค้าขายเกลือกับลาค่ะ
มาอีกแล้วนะคะนักเรียนลา
อันนี้ฟันของเขาหรอคะฟันของเรา
อันนี้หัวนะคะอันนี้หู
ตา
เหมือนลาหรือยัง
ได้
หลังนะคะแผงคอคางนะคะก็โอเคค่ะ
เรื่องของพ่อค้าขายเกลือกับลาแล้วเรื่อง
ราวมันเป็นยังไงคะครูฟ้า
กาลครั้งหนึ่งนานมาแล้ว
พ่อค้าขายเกลือเนี่ยนะคะนักเรียนก็จะต้อง
ไปขายเกลือใช่ไหม
ขายเกลือตามหมู่บ้านไหม
หมู่บ้านที่มีบ้านบ้านทำไมบ้านมันติดกัน
ขนาดนี้คะเนี่ย
เป็นหมู่บ้าน
หมู่บ้าน
ใช่ค่ะ
แล้วก็พ่อค้าขายเกลือเนี่ยก็ต้องไปที่
หมู่บ้านแล้วก็ไปขายเกลือขายเกลือขาย
เกลือก็เดินไปเดินไปเดินไปไปตามหมู่บ้าน
ต่างๆ
ซื้อเกลือไหมครับซื้อเกลือไหมครับผมมี
เกลือมาขายตะโกนใช่ไหมขายเกลือ
ใช่ค่ะก็พาลาไปด้วยนะคะ
เขามีเพื่อนเป็นลาใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าเอาลาน
เนี่ยนะคะไป
อันนี้ล่ะยืนท่าอะไรคะ
เอาลานเนี่ยนะคะไปแบกเกลือ
อ๋อเพราะเกลือเนี่ยมันหนักใช่ไหมคะถ้าพ่อ
ค้าเนี่ยต้องแบกเกลือไปด้วยแล้วก็เดินๆๆ
เนี่ยมันจะช้าแล้วมันก็เหนื่อย
แล้วก็แบกเอาลาๆๆ
ไปด้วยนะคะลาก็เดินแล้วก็แบกเกลือพ่อค้า
ขายเกลือเนี่ยก็เดินตั้งแต่ตอนเช้า
ตั้งแต่ 6 โมงเลย
ตั้งแต่ 6 เดินขายเกลือตามหมู่บ้านไม่มี
อะไรทำนะคะก็ลบแล้วก็วาดใหม่ลบแล้วก็วาด
ใหม่
6 โมงเช้าจนถึงกี่โมงอ่ะคะครูฟ้าจนถึง 6
โมงเย็นไปเลย
ขายตั้งแต่เช้ายันเย็นเลยหรอคะ
ใช่ค่ะขายตั้งแต่เช้ายันเย็นนะคะซึ่ง
กำลังเดินอยู่ก็กำลังเดินเดินระหว่างที่
กำลังจะเดินไปขายที่หมู่บ้านเนี่ย
ก็จะมีลำธาร
ลำธาร
ได้ค่ะ
พลาดหลังคาบ้านผู้หญิงเลยนะคะ
แปลว่าทางเดินไปหมู่บ้านเนี่ยมันก็เป็น
ป่าใช่ไหมมีต้นไม้มีภูเขาแล้วก็มีน้ำตก
น้ำตกไหลลงมาเป็นลำธาร
แล้วอะไรยังอยู่ข้างบนลำธารคะนั่นน่ะนี่
คือสะพาน
ไม่ได้หรอเดินในลำธารไม่ได้หรอ
ทานมัน
ก็ไม่ลึกนะไม่ต้องมีสะพานก็ได้เอาใหม่นะ
คะเดินข้ามได้พ่อค้าขายเกลือเนี่ยก็พาลา
นั้นนะคะเดินข้ามลำธาร
แต่ระหว่างที่กำลังเดิน
ล้าเนี่ยก็ล้ม
นะคะเพราะว่าอาจจะเดินไม่ดีใช่ไหมเราบอก
ว่าลานเดินไม่ดีก็เลยล้มนะคะ
ใช่
ลำธารเนี่ยก็มีก้อนหินนะมีก้อนหินก้อนหิน
มีก้อนไหมใช่มีก้อนหินก้อนหินก้อนหินก้อน
หินเยอะๆนะคะปลาเนี่ยก็เลยสะดุดก้อนหิน
แล้วก็ล้มในลำธาร
[เพลง]
หมุนไม่ได้
ร้านเนี่ยล้มในลำธารนะคะทำให้เกลือเนี่ย
ลานมีเกลือใช่ไหม
อยู่ข้างหลัง
พอล้มแล้ว
เกลือกับน้ำ
เกลือ
อยู่ในน้ำ
เกลือละลาย
ล้มในลำธารไง
แล้วเกลือใช่ไหม
ก็ละลายไปกับน้ำหมด
แล้วพ่อค้าทำยังไงอ่ะก็ไม่มีเกลือขายสิคะ
ครูฟ้าเกลือมันละลายไปแค่ 50% ค่ะผู้หญิง
ยังเหลืออีกครึ่งนึง
นะคะอีกแล้วอีก
ครึ่งนึงนะคะซึ่ง
ร้านเนี่ย
ก็ลุกขึ้นมาได้ล้มแค่แป๊บเดียวใช่ไหมล้ม
นิดหน่อย
ก็เดินลุกแต่ก็เดินข้ามลำธารมาได้ทั้งหมด
ไหมคะพอได้ยังเหลือเกลืออีกครึ่งหนึ่ง
แล้วเนี่ย
ใช่ค่ะลาก็เดินข้ามลำธารมานะคะซึ่งปลา
เนี่ยก็รู้สึกว่าเออตอนที่ลาล้มลงไปใน
ลำธาร
เกลือหายไป 50% ทำให้มันเบาไงใช่ไหม
ราเนี่ยก็แบกเกลืออีกแค่ 50% ร้านเนี่ย
คิด
ดีมากเพราะว่ามันเบา
เดินดีกว่าเพราะว่าตอนแรกเนี่ยเกลือ 100%
เนี่ยอาจจะหนักแบบ 5 กิโลกรัมใช่ไหมคะพอ
มันละลายไปครึ่งนึงแล้วเนี่ยก็เหลือ 2.5
กิโลกรัมเบาขึ้นตั้งเยอะลาก็เดินสบายขึ้น
ไหมระบายขึ้นค่ะ
ก็โอเคพ่อค้าเกลือไงก็พาลาเนี่ยกลับบ้าน
นะคะพอถึงตอนเช้า
อีก 1 วันแล้วนะอีกวันนึงนะถึงตอนเช้าพ่อ
ค้าเกลือไปซื้อเกลือเหมือนเดิม
ก็ซื้อเกลือแล้วก็เอาเกลือเนี่ยไว้ข้างบน
หลังของลานะคะเสร็จแล้วเนี่ย
ตอนที่ไปเดินขายเกลือเดินขายเกลือเนี่ยพอ
ถึงลำธาร
ลาก็โกหกแล้วก็ทำเป็นล้มลงในลำธาร
อีกครั้งนึงหรออีกครั้งนึงค่ะ
ให้เกลือละลาย
ไป 50
เหมือนเมื่อวานนี้แต่เมื่อวานนี้เนี่ย
ลาเนี่ยไม่ได้โกหกใช่ไหมเวลาเดินไม่ดีแต่
วันนี้เนี่ยลาบอกว่าอุ๊ย
ขอเกลือมันหายไปเนี่ยมันเบาขึ้นก็เลย
แล้วก็ล้มอีกครั้งนึงเหรอคะแล้วพ่อค้า
เกลือโอเคไหมพ่อค้าเกลือเนี่ยเริ่มเข้าใจ
ร้านนะคะเริ่มรู้และว่ามันเป็นเทคนิคของ
ลาใช่ไหมลาเนี่ยโกหกว่าล้ม
เกลือเนี่ยจะได้หายไปนะคะ 50% ลาก็จะได้
แบบเกลือเบาๆ
แล้วพ่อค้าเกลือคิดไหมคะว่าจะทำยังไงกับ
ลาดีก็พ่อค้าเกลือเนี่ยก็พามาเดินกลับ
บ้านไปนะคะพอเช้าวันต่อมาวันที่ 3 วันนี้
วันที่ 3 แล้ว
พ่อค้าเกลือเนี่ยนะคะก็เลยไม่ไปซื้อเกลือ
แล้วอ้าว
แต่เปลี่ยนไปซื้อนุ่นแทนค่ะ
อันนี้คือรุ่นเนี่ยหรอคะ
ก็คือนี่
นักเรียนเป็นต้นไม้ใช่ไหมแล้วมันก็จะมี
ฝักอย่างนี้นะคะแล้วไอ้นุ่นข้างในเนี่ย
เราก็จะเอามาใส่หมอนเนาะเวลาเรานอนน่ะค่ะ
นักเรียน
บางครั้งก็จะมีนุ่นนะคะ
มันนิ่มๆ
นี่คือ
จริงๆมันจะเป็นต้นอันนี้นะเห็นไหมอ่ะผู้
หญิง
อ่ะอีกทางนึงอีกทางนึงอีกทางนึงอีกทาง
หนึ่งอ่าโอเคนั่นแหละค่ะโอเคนุ่นใช่ค่ะ
หุ่นที่เราเอามาทำหมอนใช่ไหมคือประเทศไทย
นะนักเรียนอ่าอย่างเงี้ยค่ะใช่ค่ะโอเคๆ
ค่ะ
ก็นี่นะคะก็คือนุ่นพ่อค้าเกลือเนี่ยก็เลย
เปลี่ยนจากซื้อเกลือไปซื้อนุ่น
เอามาไว้ข้างหลังรานะคะก็ให้ลาแบกแล้วก็
เดินๆๆไปขายของเหมือนแล้วก็เลยเดินมาที่
ลำธาร
ค่ะ
ล้มอีกไหมคะครูฟ้า
ลาก็ล้มอีกเหมือนเดิมค่ะคุณหญิง
คิดว่าจะให้มันละลายใช่ไหมมันเป็นเกลือจะ
ได้ละลาย 50% แต่จริงๆแล้วคือนุ่นนะคะพอ
ลาล้มลงในน้ำเนี่ยนุ่นเนี่ยไม่ละลายน้ำ
ค่ะ
[เพลง]
จากที่นุ่นเนี่ยหนักอาจจะหนัก 1 กิโลกรัม
นุ่นก็เลยเพิ่มน้ำหนักเป็น 2 กิโล 3 กิโล
นะคะพอมีน้ำเข้าไปมีน้ำเข้าไปนุ่นเนี่ยก็
หนุกมากขึ้นอาจจะเป็น 3 กิโลกรัม
แล้วปลาเนี่ยลุกขึ้นยืนไหมพอล้มเสร็จแล้ว
เนี่ยเหมือนเดิมไหมคะก็ลุกขึ้นยืนค่ะแต่
ว่ามันหนักมากครั้งนี้แต่ก็ทำอะไรไม่ได้
ก็ต้องทนแบกน้ำแดกนุ่นที่มันดูดน้ำเข้าไป
หนักๆนะคะจนเดินกลับบ้านก็หนักมากใช่ไหม
ค่ะใช่ค่ะ
ตั้งแต่นั้นมาเนี่ยลาก็ไม่กล้าใช้เทคนิค
ล้มอีกเลย
ให้เกลือละลายเนี่ยขี้เกียจใช่ไหมไม่ทำ
อีกเลยเพราะว่ารู้ไม่รู้ว่าเดี๋ยวมันจะ
หนักขึ้นหรือเปล่านะคะ
ก็นี่แหละ
จบ
ตอนนี้ครูฟ้าไม่ได้เขียนนะคะเพราะว่ามอง
ไม่เห็น
จบแล้วแล้วนิทานเรื่องนี้บอกอะไรเราอ่ะคะ
คือมันจะเหมือนลาใช่ไหมเวลาเนี่ยมีเทคนิค
นะคะก็เลยใช้เทคนิคโกหก
ไม่ดีมันไม่ดี
ใช่ไหม
คนที่ใช้เทคนิคเยอะๆเนี่ย 1 วันเนี่ยก็จะ
ต้องโดนแบบลานั่นแหละ
เพราะว่ามันก็มีคนที่ IQ ดีเข้าใจรู้
เทคนิคของเราใช่ไหมเหมือนพ่อค้าเกลือก็
แบบ
ทำแบบนี้ทุกวันทุกวันโอเคฉันเอานุ่นใส่
หลังแกเลยเบาๆพอล้มในน้ำปุ๊บหนักใช่ไหมคะ
1 วันต้องมีคนรู้แน่นอนใช่ไหมถ้าเราเป็น
คนที่ซิกแซกนะคะ
นี่ก็เป็นนิทานที่ครูฟ้าเอามาเล่าให้นัก
เรียนฟังนะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้เนี่ยเดี๋ยว
เราสองคนไปก่อนละกันนะคะแล้วเจอกันใหม่
วีดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ